potocki sa parodie de la chanteuse aya
nakamura ou encore sa parodie de kalach
des vidéos qui ont été vue des millions
de fois sur internet l'humoriste
martiniquais bobby s'est surtout fait
connaître pour mettre à sa sauce des
titres à succès ou des séries télévisées
comme un parieur mais chez abel diabète
et sucrés 12 ans qu'il exerce ses
talents sur la toile mais aussi
maintenant sur scène pour la première
fois le voici à paris à la cigale la
tentation de rencontrer son public qu'on
fait une parodie ou qu'on fait une vidéo
où on équipe ou autre on voit les
commenter on voit les réactions mais ça
allait cuit
bon là confie du chsld du stand up ou
quand je fais le one man show devrait
contacter je n'ouvrais chaleur avec le
public jeudi sange platini je peux
parler gros sous la platine vous à
cacher ça qu'on a vu tu te regarde
effectivement derrière le petit écran
l'ordinateur ou à la télévente ul mans
là le voir sur cette évolution saine ben
ça montre qu'il a effectivement le
parcours qu'il a fait sur les cas du
prat stocks mais non tu as la veille la
prédiction façon originale one one
bah oui bah il a un humour hors pair le
gendarme est capable de se déguiser en
noix de coco se mettre à l'envers dos au
coach et au utah flash et mon gars tout
l'autonomie ce qui fait cela c'est ce
qui est appréciable chez lui ce qui
influence bobby surtout l'actualité la
vie chère les gilet jaune pour lui ce
cas foot et koutchoumov mortal kombat
j'aime bien rebondir sur l'actuel et
donc si c'est pas la tuer en vrai c'est
le mon quotidien mes anecdotes qui
m'arrive toujours des trucs là segal
c'était un chef salle au complet le
succès est au rendez vous de paris pour
bobby qui n'a pas résisté à l'envi de
finir son show avec une vidéo snap
chatte digne de ce nom
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]